foreign
everybody talking about a classic today
that I finally got around to
so Jacques tornur I'm hopefully I'm
pronouncing that sort of right really he
should be well known to any kind of like
serious horror fan
um because mostly because he um directed
kind of a handful of the classic RKO
like horror pictures from the 1940s
including cat people I walked with a
zombie and the leopard man which was
kind of like the male version of cat
people I guess now I had seen all three
of those movies before like um a couple
of times but for whatever reason I had
never got around to watching his later
and perhaps even more iconic 1957 movie
Night of the demon
um and this movie often appears on a lot
of people's like best horror movies of
the 1950s list so I figured it was about
time to you know address this oversight
like in my movie watching uh history
now the movie was actually entitled like
retitled curse of the demon in the
United States and Wikipedia says that
this was because they wanted to
discourage confusion with the Night of
the Iguana which was that Tennessee
Williams play that was later turned into
a movie
but this story doesn't make any sense to
me mostly because
um night of the demon or curse of the
demon came out in the U.S in 1958
because it's a British movie but Night
of the Iguana the play wasn't actually
published until 1961 and then the film
version didn't come out until 1964. so I
don't really know like why they thought
there would be confusion because it was
like this one came out first but
whatever I don't know
so Knight of the demon in case you
didn't know not to be confused with like
the awesome 80s uh movie of the same
similar name that was Knight of the
Demons you know what I mean with Linea
Quigley this is completely different
this is actually a loose retelling of
the very popular Mr James short story
from 1911 which is called casting the
runes
um that has actually been adapted for
radio and TV a bunch of times now this
version
um it takes some Liberties for sure and
expands the tail outward quite a bit as
it would have to like going to movie
length but the broad outlines of the
story are pretty much the same as the
source story so at the beginning you
have this academic whose name is
Professor Harrington and he's played by
Maurice Denham who I recognize from
Countess Dracula and he's kind of
Desperately begging this magician and
sect leader whose name is Dr Julian
Carswell
um he's played by Nyle McGinnis who
actually played Zeus and Jason in the
Argonauts that's where I recognize him
from he's been in a bunch of other stuff
as well
um so yeah so Harrington is begging this
guy to remove a curse that's been placed
on him
now evidently what had been going on was
that Harrington had been investigating
carswell's like black magic cult or
whatever you want to call it and
Carswell really didn't take too kindly
to the scrutiny I guess so Harrington
basically says well you know you were
right I didn't believe you about any of
this satanic nonsense
um but now I know better so how about
just backing off on that whole death
curse thing like pretty please with
cherries on top
so Carswell asks him hey you remember
that piece of parchment that I gave you
like without your knowledge
um you know earlier on and Harrington
says oh it actually like flew out of my
hand and like flung itself into the
fireplace and burned up and then
Carswell at this point is all like well
I'll see what I can do about that
um but apparently it's too late to
reverse the curse if you want to say
sorry about that I just couldn't resist
the rhyme there
um because as Harrington is on his way
home
he is uh beset by this
gigantic and actually pretty terrifying
looking demon that kind of like comes
toward him on a cloud of smoke it's
really cool looking actually and causes
him to like smash his car into a bunch
of power lines and he gets electrocuted
now just as a bit of an aside like I
said this movie is pretty famous it came
out in 1957. so I had actually seen
clips of the demon attack or demon
attacks uh from this movie before and
the creature itself is even pictured on
some version of like the box art and the
poster and stuff nowadays so it's not
like the monster's appearance like what
the demon looks like is like a big
shocker to Modern audiences because it's
you know the the images out there but I
had always been under the impression
because I had never sat down and watched
this movie all the way through that the
demon actually wasn't revealed or wasn't
shown until the end so when I watched
the movie for the first time I was
actually really surprised that the
creature is shown like so early in the
movie it's like the first five or ten
minutes of the movie like you know big
is life I'm still not sure how I feel
about the situation and like as I was
watching the movie I kept going back
back and forth on it so according to the
lore surrounding this movie the director
Jacques tonore he absolutely hated the
idea of showing the demon at all he
didn't want to show it
um he wanted to leave the story more
ambiguous like he wanted to say it's
like oh we don't know if there's really
a demon or if people were just like
doing the thing on themselves or
whatever which I thought was kind of a
cool idea but the producers of the movie
thought that by showing the demon like
pretty much immediately and showing the
audience that the curse was real it
would kind of like over the course of
the movie would increase the tension and
the dread when the main protagonist in
the movie like subsequently gets on the
wrong side of the same curse and is like
being stalked by the demon gonna say
though because I'm always more a fan of
like ambiguity I think I'm gonna side
slightly more with shock Turner on this
one
um I don't agree that the demons
shouldn't have been shown at all
especially because the monster design
itself like looks so cool
um oh and fun fact Ray harryhausen was
uh actually supposed to create the demon
but I guess he had like a scheduling
conflict and he couldn't end up doing it
so uh the task actually fell to the
production designer his name is Ken Adam
who I think was a German fella in my
opinion I think this movie would have
worked even better if the reality of the
curse was left in question until like
the very end of the movie when the demon
was finally like revealed you know what
I mean
um you know just big as life and twice
as ugly I mean that said I can see the
argument for the other option too like
that you know that it's real and like
you know the suspense comes from like
the main character not believing that
it's real but you're like it is dude you
know what I mean like I get that but I
will say that
the producer's idea of like showing the
demon so early like showing their hand
so early in the movie I kind of feel
like that had the unintended effect of
making the main character who was like
this big skeptic look like this smug
idiot who's like refusal to consider the
possibility of the supernatural it just
kind of had him blundering cluelessly
into danger and being a real
condescending douche about it to boot
you know what I mean so anyway uh this
aforementioned condescending douche is
named Dr John Holden and he's played by
Dana Andrews who I recognize he's been a
lot of stuff too but I actually
recognized him immediately from the
excellent and sadly underrated 1965
black comedy the loved one if you
haven't seen that see it it's great
um so shortly after Professor Harrington
gets killed by the demon
Dr Holden arrives in England to attend a
conference where Harrington was supposed
to speak about carswell's cult which he
had been investigating so like
Harrington and Holden I guess we're kind
of like colleagues and they were sort of
like working along the same lines
now Holden didn't actually know that
Harrington was dead so when he gets
there he's like really shocked at
finding out about it
um now his death is actually explained
away as a freak accident oh obviously he
was just like in a car and he crashed
into like some power lines and it
electrocuted him too bad so sad
um so Holden attends the funeral
and there he runs into Harrington's
beautiful niece Joanna who he actually
he kind of like met her before like on
the plane like they were on the same
plane over and she was like hey you're
you're blocking my way to the aisle I
have to go to the John or whatever but
it's like he didn't formally meet her
then but he but he meets her now
Joanna who's played by puggy Cummins
Peggy Cummins
she actually believes wholeheartedly
that Carswell had something to do with
her Uncle dying and she even gives
Holden like her uncle's journal in which
he wrote about like some weird
paranormal that had been going on
and how he had become convinced that
Carswell had you know basically laid a
death curse on him so naturally Holden
is just not having any of this um and he
starts mansplaining to Joanna that I've
studied all of this you know it's like
if somebody believes strongly enough
that they've been cursed like with a
death curse then it's their own
psychosomatic belief um you know that's
the thing that kills them but that
satanic curses and black magic and all
that stuff are absolutely not real
now after Holden decides that he's going
to continue Harrington's investigation
into Carswell though little weird things
start happening for example uh Carswell
actually approaches Holden in the
reading room like of the British museum
like in the library and he's like Holden
is there looking for this like a cult
book that Harrington had mentioned in
his notes but it's missing mysteriously
but uh Carswell comes in and says oh I
have a copy of that book and I'll loan
it to you if you come out to my house or
whatever so Carswell gives Holden this
like visiting card that has like his
address printed on it and all that but
it also has a handwritten message on it
that seems to be low-key threatening
Holden uh that his time is running out
and then later on the handwriting
disappears off the card and he takes it
like Holden takes it to all these
different tests like to have all these
tests on it being like I know I saw that
handwriting on there but they
can't find any like scientific trace of
it like it was never there so there's
that
also Holden discovers that all of the
pages of his date book like after a
certain date have been ripped out not by
him uh and he doesn't really know how
that happened and it's almost as though
uh you know hey bud you're not going to
be needing a calendar like after that
particular time because you're going to
be you know dead so then Joanna tells
Holden that her uncle had the exact same
thing happen to him like the pages in
his date book were also mysteriously
ripped out after a certain date and that
date also happened to be the day that
Harrington died in the car crash again
Holden is just not buying it he says oh
Harrington dying on that particular day
that was just a strange coincidence or
it was a case of self-fulfilling
prophecy
now Holden actually does go to see
Carswell in his palatial estate
it's a yeah it's it's a big thing like
he lives with his mom but it's like this
big huge like English Palace type
Mansion type situation
and when he goes there like the magician
is actually really cordial and very
genteel and like you know offers him tea
and all that but he doesn't
absolutely does not try to hide the fact
that he's like yep totally summoned a
demon to curse you and he basically
tells him directly it's like you're
gonna die in three days if you don't
knock off this investigation
and then like to prove to Holden that he
actually does have magical powers and
he even kind of stirs up this
Cyclone tornado kind of thing like a
windstorm while him and Holden are like
out in the garden but Holden is still
not convinced by this thinking it's all
just kind of like parlor tricks or again
just like a weird anomaly that's like a
coincidence and then when Holden is
reading Harrington's diary he actually
discovers that before the professor died
he got past a piece of parchment with
runic symbols on it heads casting the
runes which was with the name of the
original story was
um and he got past it like without his
knowledge like it was slipped into his
stuff and this was the scrap of paper
that got burned in the fire like at the
beginning of the movie
so Joanna actually persuades Holden to
see if Carswell passed him a similar
piece of paper and lo and behold it
turns out that Carswell actually had
slipped one kind of surreptitiously into
Holden's stuff while he was at the
British museum like all like he was like
oh I knocked all your off the table
and that that was when he put it in
there like when he's put it back up so
while he's like holy like the dude
did do the same thing this little piece
of parchment like whips itself out of
Holden's hand almost as like it has a
mind of its own and it tries to
incinerate itself in the fireplace but
it can't get in there because there's
like a big metal screen in front of it
so Holden like pulls it out and like
sticks it in his pocket just in case
he's maybe starting to think a little
bit it's like maybe there is something
kind of weird going on here
and then after like shortly after this
there's kind of a I gotta say it's kind
of like a silly scene where carswell's
Mom organizes a seance like you're not
really sure if carswell's Mom is like on
carswell's side or is trying to help
Holden and Joanna like it's really never
made super clear but she kind of puts
together this Seance and Holden and Joey
and I go to it and then Professor
Harrington who remember is dead
apparently communicates through this
medium guy that's there and he warns
Holden pretty much that the curse is
real and it's like hey you need to go to
carswell's house and find this
translation that he has like of the
runic symbols now even though Holden is
still kind of skeptical at this point
and he thinks the Seance is you know
pretty much horseshit he kind of agrees
to go with Joanna and he's like okay
well we're gonna straight up break into
carswell's house to find this translated
book like Joanna was gonna go do it by
herself but Holden of course like
Stephanie's like I'm the man I'll I'll
do the breaking and entering here you
know what I mean so Holden gets busted
though like it was just right in the in
the study there with like gives like
what I wasn't doing anything not only
that but he gets attacked in Carswell
study by a sweet little kitty whose name
is gray Malkin and he actually appears
as a panther like for a few brief
seconds while he's attacking and um you
know also like tears up his clothes he
doesn't like him up or anything
like that but he just tears his clothes
all up now Carswell comes in and he's
just like cool as a cucumber and he's
like oh yeah I did that whole thing
using magic like you didn't see a
panther it was just this little kitty
right here what are you talking about
you know what I mean but it was that
kind of stuff so Holden again still
maintaining his very skeptical stance uh
despite all all of the mounting evidence
to the contrary so as Holden is leaving
the house because he's like look I'm not
gonna call the cops or anything like
that just get the out of here he's
like look I'll even let you go down the
main driveway instead you like creeping
around the back of the house like when
you got in he's like I'll turn all the
lights on in the driveway for you to go
out to your car and everything like you
know I'm a good sport about your
breaking and entering
um but Holden innocent this was like
okay
so Holden says
um no I'm gonna go through the woods
because that's the way I came and he's
like and I that's my only Superstition
is that I like to go back the way I came
which I was kind of like okay that seems
like a random
a random way of just like getting him to
go back through the creepy woods but
okay whatever so Carswell is basically
like I wouldn't go in the woods if I
were you but of course like Holden is
like no I'm going through the
woods I'm the man like I said
um so predictably he gets chased Through
the Woods by this creepy like smoke
configuration like I said the smoke
effect is like really cool
like coming through the sky or whatever
and um there's also this kind of because
I forgot to mention it before but when
the demon attacks like when the demon
attacks like Professor Harrington at the
beginning there's kind of like this
poofy smoke thing and then the demon
comes out and then there's like this
real high pitched it almost sounds like
crickets like a bunch of crickets like a
really high-pitched kind of noise so
he's like being chased through the woods
through this and the Smoky thing and the
Crickets and he's like holy oh my
God and he like just starts running his
ass off like toward the car but all of
this still doesn't make Holden like stop
his investigation though like he's still
doing it and in the course of this
investigation him and his colleagues
they hypnotize this catatonic man they
kind of like mentioned him before his
name is Rand Hobart and he was a member
of carswell's cult
now while he's under hypnosis he says to
everybody that he was also chosen for
death and he was passed a parchment like
without his knowledge but that he
managed to because obviously he's still
alive but he managed to avoid the curse
by sneaking the paper back to the person
who gave it to him
so hold in basically because he still
has the parchment that Carswell gave him
as well so he takes as pocket he's like
is this the parchment is it was it like
this and then Hobart flips the
out because he thinks that Holden
is trying to give it to him you know
what I mean and he's just like oh no and
I do like I guess that'll like make the
demon come after him now but then in a
complete this is a completely
nonsensical he tears off down the hall
like he's so scared by Holden trying to
give him this piece of paper that he
just like jumps off the thing runs off
down the hall and leaps out the window
and dies so I was like so you wouldn't
take the paper because it meant that
you'll die but then he just goes and
like Yates himself off a building and
ties anyway I mean it seems kind of
counterproductive is all I'm saying
maybe there's a whole thing where it's
like well it's better to just like die
by jumping out a window like suicide
then getting eaten by the demon or maybe
the demon takes you to like a turtle
damnation or something like that whereas
just jumping out a window wouldn't I
don't really know but I was just kind of
like
I was like well you died anyway so you
know why didn't you just like chill out
I don't know okay so at this point like
the whole being chased by clearly
Supernatural smoke and crickety noises
in the woods situation has finally
gotten Holden on board with the fact
that he is uh the recipient of a death
curse but now thanks to Crazy Hobart he
has the knowledge of how to combat it
but time is running very very short he
only has like at the point that he kind
of like realizes this he only has a
couple hours left before he's like
supposed to die now he finds out that
Carswell is going to be taking a train
to Southampton like that evening
and he also discovers that Carswell has
kind of like Bewitched Joanna into
coming with him I'm assuming is like
insurance or something like that so
Holden actually manages to get on the
same train like you know right before it
leaves the station and then when he
finds Carswell and Joanna in the
compartment there's kind of like a
little bit of back and forth with Holden
trying to like return the parchment to
Carswell like without cars while like
figuring it out you know what I mean
um so Carswell is on to this though
obviously and he's like getting real
touchy about it so he just refuses to
take anything that Holden tries to hand
him it's like like he loans him some
matches like to lay the cigarette and
then he's like here have the matchbook
back and he's like no you keep it you
know what I mean so he's he's on to this
whole but it so happens
that cars that uh that Holden was
actually able to sneak the paper into
the pocket of carswell's Overcoat like
while he was doing all this other
with the matches and everything so after
the magician like hops off the train
like the piece of paper like blows out
because I guess the whole it's implied
that the piece of paper has to like be
destroyed and then the demon will come
you know what I mean so it whips itself
out of your hand and like throws itself
into a fireplace or does whatever or
Burns itself up somehow and then the
demon is just like oh time time to come
and like up you know what I
mean so he so he's chasing the paper
like desperately like down the train
tracks and it keeps whipping itself out
of his hand and it's like it finally
like burns up and then you know here
comes the smoke and here comes the demon
and probably I think this is like the
scene that always gets shown this is
like the most famous scene in the movie
where the demon just like starts like
steaming down the uh the train
tracks almost like it's a train itself
like it's this kind of and it's this big
like medieval looking demon like
wings and Claws and it's like it's huge
and it's really really cool looking so
it basically like attacks him and uh
it's imp I think it's implied that
nobody can see the demon except for the
person that it's coming after
um so carswell's death because the demon
does kill him is explained away as him
getting run over by the train and like
dragged along the track so the demon
really mangled the dude apparently so
like I said
I said one of the better horror films
from the 1950s
um you know it's obviously not all that
scary by today's standards and it's
pretty easy to see where it's gonna go
but overall I found myself really
enjoying it
um Dr Holden like the main protagonist
he's a little bit Bland and also like
kind of pompous which is sort of like
infuriating
um at least until he Twigs onto the fact
that you know an actual demon is like
gunning for his ass and maybe he needs
to do something about that but I also I
liked the interplay between him and
Joanna because Joanna just did not take
any from him at all and told him
off like multiple times for being just a
conceited jack wagon and she's like look
the demon is real you need to do
something about this I don't even
care you know it's so that was good
um the actor like Nyle McGinnis was also
quite delightful as the uh as Carswell
who is the villain he was very
charismatic and like really Sinister but
he didn't really go over the top like he
always came across as like really
friendly but there was all there was
always this kind of like evil like
lurking below the surface and I thought
it was like a really good performance
now I could have done without the Seance
scene
um because that seemed like it was only
there for kind of mild comic relief
purposes and sort of conveyed
information that the audience pretty
much already knew or could have figured
out on their own
um but I I mean I didn't really mind it
all that much because I it was like
pretty short I also kind of wish the
demon hadn't been shown at the beginning
of the movie like you know when
Harrington got killed
um because I think that then you know
who if you were watching the movie you
would have had cause to doubt whether
the curse was real or not and then you'd
have like this you'd be blindsided by
this big reveal at the end of those like
massive medieval looking demon like
steaming down the train tracks and that
would have been real cool and again that
demon just looks really really awesome
like especially for 1957. but I mean
these are like just really minor
nitpicks and you know it's very very
easy even watching it nowadays to see
why this movie is just like so revered
and it gets brought up a lot when
they're talking about like really good
movies really classic movies from the
1950s
um I'm gonna say it's not quite as like
atmospheric or like as stylish maybe as
Jacques Turner's 1940s movies like cat
people and stuff but I mean it's still
undeniably a classic and if you're super
super into horror you should probably do
yourself a favor and see it so that will
do it for this flickers of fear and
remember to like share and subscribe and
comment and all of that other good stuff
and I'll see you guys again on the next
one bye